this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
hey crazies in my last video I explained
how mass and energy were the same thing
and that got a bunch of you wondering
what the heck is energy I've said a lot
about energy on this channel but it's
spread over multiple videos it's time to
put it all in one place hmm where do we
start this definitions we have to be
careful though physics tends to use a
lot of ordinary words in not so ordinary
ways and energy is no exception there
are a lot of ways we use this word in
the English language I feel the energy
of the spirits definitely not what we're
talking about oh man I am so out of
energy good example but not really a
definition I get energy from the power
grid again good example but not a
definition a typical definition for
physical energy is the ability or
capacity to do work but that just raises
more questions what the heck is works
gotta go to work work work work okay the
point is we can't understand energy
without understanding work we need both
together but let's make something clear
energy and work are just properties
they're numbers objects and particles
are physical things that exist objects
and particles have properties like
energy and work work work work work take
a ball for example we can label where it
is by assigning a property called
position we can label its motion by
assigning a property called velocity an
object can have motion and that motion
is real but the velocity we assign to it
is not it's just a useful number
properties are useful because they
measure something we want to know all of
these properties here measure all of
these things here we need to figure out
exactly what energy and work are
measuring work is a little easier to
understand so let's try to figure that
one out first everybody's working for
the weekend a typical definition for
work is that it's done on an object by a
force as long as that force contributes
in some way to how the object moves
let's say you wanted to do work on this
book
all you have to do is push on it with
enough force to make it move that force
times the books displacement is the work
done on the book we know a force
measures the influence or interaction
amount so it makes perfect sense that
forces are involved in work the key here
is the displacement in order for work to
be done on that book it has to move from
one place to another if the object
doesn't go anywhere then no work is done
on it no matter how much it feels like
work to you a working class hero is
something to be stuff has to happen for
work to be done in fact that tells us
exactly what it is work is the amount of
stuff that has happened or if you're
making predictions the amount of stuff
that will happen so what's that make
energy well let's look back at the
definition if energy is the ability or
capacity to do work and work is the
amount of stuff that has or will happen
that energy is the amount of stuff that
could potentially happen there's an
upper limit to how much stuff could
happen and that upper limit is measured
as energy thanks for liking and sharing
what do you think the crazies are gonna
be satisfied with you just leaving it
like that
okay I guess you're right okay so there
is a lot of stuff that could happen
lifting swimming climbing dancing
swinging waving running slithering with
doing other things
boiling electrifying chemical reactions
nuclear explosions yeah let's just say
there are a lot of options right so how
can all of those things be the same
thing there are all examples of energy
being used to do work if you're lifting
a box
you're turning chemical energy in your
body into gravitational energy that
change does work on the Box moving it
upward you didn't use all the energy
inside your body to do that work just
just a little bit all of the energy in
your body is all this stuff you could
possibly do the work is what you
actually do that box now has energy it
can use to do stuff like fall down the
gravitational energy is gradually turned
into kinetic energy on the way down
that's not even all the energy inside
that box sure it has gravitational in
Connecticut or
but it also has thermal energy because
it's not an absolute zero and a whole
list of other energies tied up in the
material none of which are getting used
to do work the only work done is the Box
falling that's the stuff that's
happening so how do we measure these
things anyway well we don't at least not
directly
unlike position and velocity energy and
work are properties that are hidden from
view we have to calculate their value by
measuring something else if it's
gravitational energy we measure a
distance from some reference location
usually the ground and then calculate
the energy using some equations twice as
high means twice the energy meaning it
could do twice as much stuff if it's
kinetic energy we calculate it with a
measured speed twice the speed means
four times the energy or four times as
much stuff there are equations for
finding all types of energy and every
single one adds to what an object could
possibly do if you can change that
energy from one type to another or move
it from one object to another you're
doing work something will be happening
warping in the coalmine going down down
there are a lot of different places we
can find energy so it helps to split
them into categories we could take the
list and organize it based on where we
find them but there's something we can
do that's a bit more useful all energies
can be described by two generic types
potential energy related to location and
kinetic energy related to motion that's
all there really is remember the purpose
of energy is to show us what could
happen and the only way things happen is
if they move from one place to another
location and motion pretty much cover
that so you can label all of these as
potential and/or kinetic energy nuclear
energy is just the potential energy of
protons and neutrons chemical energy is
just the potential energy in chemical
bonds thermal energy is Wiggly kinetic
energy plus some material potential
energy but don't locate in motion depend
on your point of view yep and that's
just more evidence that energy isn't
something tangible energy is not a thing
by itself it's a property of things so
there's no reason in particular we'd all
have to agree on how much is there if
location and motion are relative to the
observer then so
potential and kinetic energy there's
always some kind of reference point
where you define zero for kinetic energy
it's usually your own speed to observers
moving at different speeds aren't going
to agree on the motion of a third object
so they're not going to agree on its
energy either that's perfectly fine
because energy is not a tangible thing
it's just a number and a similar thing
happens with potential energy for
gravitational energy the reference is
usually the ground but there's nothing
special about that choice you could move
that reference around and it's totally
fine what matters is the difference in
energy between two events across time
that's the work done that's what's
actually happening she looks hot both
and money so what the heck is energy
energy is the amount of stuff that could
happen but in the end all that really
matters is what does happen and that
takes work so got any questions about
energy please ask in the comments thanks
for liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from Dale
Hildebrand who said the idea of
relativistic mass can lead to false
conclusions well yeah sure it can I I
even said in the video that it can get
really confusing but that doesn't mean
that relativistic mass isn't real it
just means that it stopped being useful
anyway crazies thanks for watching